but even here there's no escape from the
storm
I have to get out of this breathing land
best I can do is just find a quick
shelter behind the wind shadow of these
trees I dig down through the snow at the
base of a spruce making the hole just
big enough to fit myself into snow is
the key to keeping warm out here fresh
snow is up to 95 percent trapped air and
that air acts as a powerful insulator
trapping heat and preventing it from
escaping that's why the Cree keep it up
around their temporary shelters and why
many animals survive the winters buried
in snow cave by digging down into the
snow like this and then using my
snowshoes to create a roof I'm not only
protecting myself from the wind by
creating an insulated air pocket where I
can try to stay warm
all I can do is hunker down and wait for
the storm to pass priority right now is
to keep myself warm if this storm goes
on until dark I won't be able to build a
shelter or light a fire and without them
I will not survive through the night
[Music]